As I said, these reactive systems are hard to build. You probably have heard
of examples of complex systems getting into deadlock states or
otherwise freezing up because of the common [UNKNOWN] blowup in
complexity that occurs from all of the internal things that are going on.
So, you have to spend some time in getting these things right. And
some kind of behavioral modeling technique, like statecharts, okay,
can be very helpful to getting that kind of assurance. Besides statecharts,
UML provides other diagrams that can be used for understanding behavior.
Okay, we've already seen these in our review of UML, activity diagrams,
sequence diagrams, collaborations, use cases, communication, timing and
interaction overview diagrams. Okay? Outside of UML, there's a couple of
other behavioral modeling approaches which I'll just mention to you, we won't go
into it. One of those is temporal logic. If you've heard of model checking and
model checking tools these are ways of modelling system and
asking can I ever get into this certain state that I don't want to get into,
okay. Am I ensured that I can't get into it, okay and
model checking tools can help you get answers to that problem.
Another notation for expressing concurrency is process algebras.
These allow you to specify what things can go on concurrently and
the reads and write behavior between the concurrently executing activities.
We will be looking further into statecharts, we will do, be doing an exercise
that ask you to learn the features. This is such an essential part of getting
models right that want to make sure that you have kind of acquired that skill.